what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with night terrors and this is
Shazam the god of nightmares and he's
watching on as everybody in the Shazam
family Burns to death
I don't know why I think that's funny
that's not funny at all so the thing
about this is this basically is just the
result of what's going on with the night
terrors event which is to say basically
all the superheroes and even the super
villains are just kind of stuck in this
sort of nightmare comatose state whether
forced to endure these nightmare
experiences over and over and over again
for Mary Marvel Billy Batson basically
becoming evil like Black Adam is like
her worst nightmare and in fact when she
woke up in this nightmare realm the
other members of the Shazam family
specifically Darla and a few others were
trying to get water because there was a
fire but there was no water anywhere and
that's when Billy bassen showed up and
somebody said no I'm just gonna let him
die and in fact he tries to stop her
when she goes to their aid now the funny
thing about this is that when she goes
to attack he shouts Shazam and turns
back into Billy Batson and that
basically stops her because the reality
here is that Mary is not aware of the
fact that she's in a nightmare now for
those of you guys who would look at the
circumstance and see like a house in a
Barren Wasteland and all that kind of
stuff and you would think that would
alert her to the fact that she is in
basically a dream state or really just
some place that's not the real world one
of the things to keep in mind with the
Shazam family is they're routinely going
on these wild and zany Adventures right
like Shazam in the seven magic lands
they end up in these places where you
like come aboard and you bring along all
your hopes and dreams and together
you'll find everything that you're
looking for right the compass is Left
Behind and it'll only slow you guys down
so they end up in this situation where
their heart will be their guide and they
raise the sails and then take the hell
right that's really what you run into in
the Shazam stories and so because of
this I really hope people got the
reference because of this it's not
something she's immediately aware of
right and so even then when Shazam
basically takes away her ability to use
her own powers she does exactly what you
would expect with somebody like Mary
Marvel and just goes running into the
house to try to rescue them anyway now
that's one of the more important things
in all seriousness when it comes to the
Shazam family the reason why the power
was even bestowed upon them in the first
place was because of the strength of
character that they had that sure not
necessarily having any abilities still
they would go forward and engage in what
you and I would consider to be tasks of
bravery and so that's why they were even
granted that ability in the first place
now what's so interesting here is that
despite her being in a dream state she
says the word Shazam and then suddenly
her powers emerge and that's when she's
met with the rest of the Shazam family
coming to this realization she's been
sleeping this whole time but then in
turn we find out that's not even real
because her father manifests is what's
basically like a giant bug and tells her
to go back to sleep so in the real world
she's totally out of it right like
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday right
she's like saying Shazam getting her
powers saying Shazam going back to
normal over and over and over again
because she simply just says the words
in a dream state and it doesn't matter
what mental state you're in as long as
you say the word the transformation will
happen and so once she really kind of
comes to on Friday she still hasn't
quite figured out that she's in a dream
and so as she's talking to her parents
they start saying like you were calling
the Thunder last night and so on and so
forth a lot of what seems to mirror
what's going on in the real world and to
her mind it all seems legitimate until
she gets into like this impossibly long
taxi and is taken to a quote unquote
dream specialist now along the way the
driver reveals himself to actually be
insomnia again this main villain for the
night terror story that's really just
kind of jumping in and out of people's
own nightmares looking for this
ridiculously powerful artifact called
The Nightmare stone that would allow him
to keep the world in a sleeping State
and then conquer all of existence and so
even then where she's kind of taunted
that she can't protect her family she
can't keep her family safe the idea
behind this is to sort of keep them
trapped in this realm and that's why so
much psychological warfare is used
because if you can keep somebody
mentally and emotionally tied down to
where they are then their focus and
their efforts would be kept in the Here
and Now despite talk of saying like I
can save my family I can keep them safe
the whole conversation keeps her
believing she can affect the world she's
in and so long as she believes it's real
she'll stay trapped in it that was the
benefit of Damien Wayne Damien Wayne
realize incredibly fast that he was in a
dream world and then learned to control
his own dreams and then engineered his
own Escape Mary Marvel is no Damien
Wayne she's cool but she's no Damian
Wayne and so that's when she starts to
put two and two together because she
ends up in this kind of sleep Specialist
Hospital which of course is twisted and
screwed up and all that kind of stuff
it's a very dark and Sinister looking
place and when she goes to say the word
she exam she's immediately snatched up
by Billy Batson and every time she tries
to say the word she basically starts
kind of coughing up and spewing out
stuff that keeps her from being able to
complete it and so Billy Batson arrives
on the scene and says that's my word not
yours you want to say it to save
everyone but I'm the only one who really
knows how to use it and he says let me
show you and what he does is he brings
each member of her family in front of
her shouts the word they're electrocuted
and they die he literally kills her
family in front of her and it is it's
dark man it's brutal like every single
person ends up getting killed and so
ultimately after everybody's dead he
walks up to her to say the word Shazam
now that's where things start to get
cool and that's kind of the nature of
her magic because one of the things to
remember when it comes to the members of
the Shazam family they're not like
Superman right where like they're
exposed to a yellow sun and they get
powers and they're super strong and fast
no no their abilities come from Gods out
side and within the realm of the DC
Universe right the wisdom of Minerva
different things like that Gods would
not be affected by the power of insomnia
at least we're largely led to believe
they wouldn't because gods don't really
sleep at least not as far as we're aware
and so because of that the wisdom of
Minerva comes into play not in so much
that like Minerva shows up and touches
her forehead and says let me show you
the truth but really more in the sense
that she starts to realize she really is
in a dream state nothing she's seeing is
real and that's why I say it's really
cool the way this is done because for
someone like Mary Marvel and the crazy
escapades they've had things like this
happen all the time so how do you
differentiate between a circumstance you
encounter every single week and suddenly
being in a dream state the idea of Billy
being evil that's the kicker to her
that's the thing that sets her off
because he refers to himself as the
captain as Billy and that's when she
says no Billy Batson would never turn
into a villain he would die by before he
did except for the Injustice Universe
when he became a bad guy but outside of
that right I mean he was a bad guy sure
Superman killed him whatever he was a
bad guy like you cannot argue that he
wasn't so the cool thing here is that
ultimately the fight breaks out between
the two of them we basically end up
learning that Billy Batson is
effectively insomnia masquerading as
Billy which most all of you probably
figured out by now the real kicker about
this is now Mary has to figure a way out
and that's the thing here it's one thing
to understand and to realize she's in a
dream state it's another to do something
about it and so once this takes place
she literally leaves her physical form
and starts jumping into the bodies of
the other members of her family in order
to one part wake them up to the reality
of what's going on but also help them
overcome their own dreams Darla has the
most adorable dream if we're being
honest with ourselves right like it's
just like these Giants but because Darla
is a diminutive girl right she's the
youngest like adults are the things that
terrify her the most and they're kind of
like these omnipresent overwhelming
things it's like the cutest thing ever
right so like Mary teams up with Darla
and like they beat up the adults
something that we all wanted to do when
we were little kids
all we wanted to do was just be left
alone and eat candy for dinner what's so
wrong with that but the thing about this
is that of course once they overcome
these adults then Mary realizes this is
a possibility and so then she jumps into
the dream of Eugene and then in turn
helps Eugene now the funny thing about
this is that insomnia does reappear and
it even goes so far as to say it doesn't
matter whose dream you're in I have
access to everybody's dream but whether
you consider to be hokey or one of the
Hallmarks of the Shazam storyline the
power of family
basically prevails here right like she
overcomes this guy and then in turn
shout Shazam that gives Eugene his
powers and the kids that were bullying
him and that were picking on him Eugene
helps them to understand their place in
the bigger picture and then following
that she ends up going to basically see
uh Pedro Pedro's giving like this great
big huge speech on a tour bus
everybody's laughing at him because he
has no pants so she shouts Shazam he
gets his suit he gets his pants and then
he probably helps the tourists
understand their place in the bigger
picture maybe even help them finish with
all their living but the thing here is
that jumping from one person to the next
basically granting them their powers and
then waking them up to what's going on
they're all coming to the realization
that they are in a dream state now
that's one of the things about the
Shazam family and it's really what kind
of makes them unique in a lot of
different ways but even with Mary Marvel
herself right where she goes and like
rescues her dad and then brings the
essence of her father into her mother's
mind and they become Pirates which is
amazing I love Pirates I absolutely love
the idea of pirates it's just like the
most amazing concept ever of course
insomnia steps in again and in fact the
fight between the two of them
transitions through dream states right
like jumping through other people's
dreams fighting through other people's
dreams you don't really get to see a
whole lot of what's going on but the
real fear right the real meat and
potatoes of what drives the fear of Mary
Marvel is that she'll ultimately be
forgotten that Billy Batson as a
superhero will become so popular and so
famous that nobody will remember Mary
Marvel now this is kind of a funny thing
because it's actually a reference to DC
Comics in the 70s and 80s for those of
you guys who don't know what I'm talking
about here when Billy Batson first
showed up on the scene in DC Comics he
was actually a product of a company
called faucet Publications he was more
popular than Superman so DC sued Fawcett
basically over copyright rounds the
lawsuit stayed in court for like 10
years eventually DC got the rights to
Shazam as a character and then shelved
him until the 1970s so there was nobody
out there that could challenge the
popularity of Superman but once he came
back him and the Shazam family were in
their owned Universe called Earth s but
with characters like Mary Marvel going
into like the 80s and the 90s and the
2000s she largely became a forgotten
character her and the rest of the Shazam
family they were there but nobody was
ever really there for them they were
there for Shazam so it's a great meta
textual commentary on the history of her
relationship with like DC as a
publishing company and even like us as
the comic book readers it's pretty cool
right it's pretty awesome but of course
the rest of the Shazam family basically
show up invading her dream and then they
in turn attack insomnia and what it does
is it allows all of them to effectively
wake up to the reality of what's going
on Mary Marvel is the one who wakes up
in this story but the real kind of
indication is like everybody will start
coming up as well but the funny thing
here is that even when she awakes and
she looks out the window she sees what
looks like an evil Shazam right now of
course it is insomnia momentarily here
in the real world but DC could build off
of us and they could in turn springboard
this into a story that focuses on an
evil version of Shazam that's not Black
Adam and I'm not gonna lie to you guys
that would be pretty dope but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end if you need to get caught up
on night terrors make sure you click
this link to the night terrors playlist
and I will catch you all later
Bruce